food and water ran out four days ago
boxers shall run out tomorrow morning
I've been when I drift off I will dream
about you it's how I see you
[Music]
danos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
we lost friends you lost family
you lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
hey everybody is Charlie so we got to
talk about fan OHS the Infinity Gauntlet
and what they're doing with the story of
Avengers 4 because I know a lot of
people have thought that there is a
greater threat because of all the
merchandising teasing that yes there are
other big threats in Avengers 4 but it's
not quite what you think so we got to
break it down because a lot of this they
give you in the trailer even though it's
meant to be really cryptic and
misleading a lot of this still comes
from the Infinity Gauntlet
comic book story so comic book fans will
be really happy we're doing a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite endgame trailer
moment on the video so you watch this
trailer you get a little bit of fan oohs
he's on his farm on Titan 2 which is
what the Russos call it is sort of like
a remade version of his homeworld but
the way they talk about it they say that
it's not the original version of titans
so it's not like he brought a whole
bunch of his people back to life he's
effectively almost there all by himself
his armored scarecrow is still there in
the field from the end of infinity war
that's a big comic book moment him
hanging up his armor because his journey
he feels like is done like I've
accomplished what I set out to do so I
could take my tools of war and hang them
up although he hasn't completely given
up the Infinity Gauntlet even though a
couple years have gone by his wounds
have healed from Stormbreaker so he's
completely back to normal relatively
speaking you don't really see it from
this other than the charred remains of
the gauntlet that's still on his left
hand but the Russos did reveal in
addition to all the things that happened
to him at the end of the movie is
powerful is he was naturally his arm is
now still permanently damaged by trying
to wield that much power they kind of
briefly address that during guardians of
the galaxy the first movie when the
collectors talking about other beings
trying to share in the power of the
Infinity stones and being completely
wiped out even star-lord at the time who
was still half celestial and still had
the power that ego the Living Planet had
given to him genetically was barely able
to hold on to the Power Stone with the
help of the other Guardians before they
had to let go of it because they were
just flying apart at the seams that
their bodies would have just turned into
pure energy if they'd continued to hold
on to that so the fact that Thanos is
able to hold one
Palma's hand without it really hurting
him that bad tells you how powerful he
is at the beginning of infinity war so
when you see him plop the mine stone in
the gauntlet and you see that energy
coursing through him that's not so much
ecstasy as it is pain him trying to
weather the pain of all that energy
destroying his body make all the jokes
you want to about him finding pleasure
in pain he does seem like that kind of
person so you get like a really quick
shot of him with the charred gauntlet
obviously that had nothing to do with
Stormbreaker
and the stones themselves are just fine
it's just that the gauntlet itself was a
conduit that allowed him to wield the
power of all six at the same time that's
why III made it for him is because
Thanos could probably hold one of the
stones and use it by himself but if he
bare palmed all six of the stones it
would kill him just like it would kill
any other living being so the gauntlet
itself actually did serve a real
functional purpose it does have magical
properties and it also allowed him to
snap his fingers there were a lot of
questions about how you snap your
fingers with a metal gauntlet just keep
in mind that it was magical just like
storm breakers magical both made by
Eitri imbued with a lot of power the
merchandizing we saw a little while ago
made us question whether or not santos
would be the main villain and obviously
there's a course of action that the
avenger sort of present to you in this
they have to find some way to undo to
underst
half of all life in the universe because
you see the imagery of all the dust
flying back into form the a reform the a
like they're reforming the Avengers
during Avengers 4 so that the original
Avengers can reform like they did during
the original Avengers movie have their
Avengers Assemble moment with the help
of Captain Marvel there are a lot of
shots in the trailer of the trade on the
original Avengers movie like they're all
broken it's a mirror for that scene
where Nick Fury comes up and plops
Coulson's cards on the table they have
to figure out what to do next and have
their rally moment like oh we lost
because we weren't working as a team so
this is the exact same thing just you
know multiply it to the nth degree
because half of all life has been erased
so the trailer is basically telling you
that they're trying to reverse what
Thanos did so a lot of people are
focusing mostly on the just basic idea
that the Avengers will have to steal
stones from him one at a time
revisiting moments from earlier films
and funny ways that's why we have the
VAR effing technology that's why we have
the quantum realm the idea of multiple
realities the multiverse
you can trade on moments like big
moments from earlier Avengers films
while also continuing on this quest to
reverse what the anos did so if all that
merchandising earlier this year was
confusing teasing a greater threat
making you think that somebody else was
going to be the main villain and not fan
OHS then just remember that he still is
very much the main villain even though
the movie itself is trading on a very
different part of the Infinity Gauntlet
comic book story even though the
gauntlet is still very important to
their plan and the Infinity stones it's
just not as much the main MacGuffin as
it was during Avengers infinity war and
there still are other threats it's just
that they're not gonna be like focusing
the entire film on this other big threat
Thanos is still very much the target
they just released new promo art for the
official Avengers end game title and it
is very much SHINee
Santos purple so that just reminds you
that Thanos is still very much the focus
of what's going on but if you haven't
read that Infinity Gauntlet comic book
there are a couple really important
things that happen after that osnaps
half of all life out of the universe
obviously the gauntlet trades hands a
couple times
nebula wields the gauntlet for a brief
period but what happens is is towards
the end of the story part of the reason
why Thanos loses the power of the
Infinity stones is Adam warlock who's a
big part of that storyline judges him
from the soul world you have to assume
that a lot of his story will go to
Doctor Strange and Gamora like Gamora is
the person from the soil world that's
speaking to Thanos and in the comic book
that was mostly at a warlock doing that
so the really interesting turn is
towards the end of that story Adam
warlock tells Thanos that he was
destined to lose the power of the
Infinity Gauntlet because within the
soul world of the soul gem Adam warlock
was able to see fan OSes soul and knew
that he felt himself unworthy of this
great power so at all points through
infinity war Thanos seems pretty sure of
himself he's been trying to enact this
plan for eons he was going around planet
to planet old-school-style before he got
the power of the Infinity stones the
Infinity stones just enabled him to do
that with a snap of his finger but at no
point do you ever hear anyone
questioning his worth he never questions
his worth he's always completely sure of
his plan but at the end of the comic
book Infinity Gauntlet story the reason
why he abandons his quest for power and
becomes a simple farmer is is because he
comes to terms with the idea that he was
Ned
were meant to wield that much power like
he never truly felt like it belonged to
him even though through the whole first
part of the story while he's going to
town on the universe and all the
Avengers you don't really get into that
so even though there's a lot of
different stuff happening during
avengers endgame and there's people
talking mostly about the plot turns a
lot of Avengers endgame is The Avengers
and also Thanos questioning themselves
in a much deeper way much more
introspective like you sort of turn
inward and look at yourselves as you
reflect on the last 22 Marvel films so
even though a lot of the plot twists
they've already used from the actual
comic book Infinity Gauntlet the really
big thing that the Avengers and actually
primarily Gamora in Doctor Strange
although I would say mostly Gamora for a
lot of this is get fan oohs to question
himself did I actually do the right
thing because think about it this way if
the Avengers are able to steal the
gauntlet back from him then what would
stop him from just amassing more force
and then going back to reassemble the
gauntlet and then just going back and
forth back and forth at a certain point
one side or the other has to give up
like and obviously it's not gonna be the
Avengers there's no way they're gonna
give up obviously they want to end on a
really high moment so it's a foregone
conclusion that they fix everything and
bring at least most of the dusted people
in the universe back so that means that
Thanos at some point will have to give
up because he's so powerful he always
finds a way to come back he's died so
many times in the comics and come back
from death he's so overpowered that
stories about fan OHS aren't so much
about him just beating up other people
and order the people beating him up is
more of him coming to the same
conclusion as the Avengers about what
the right course of action is and even
though he's never going to be allies
with the Avengers he finds some other
way to justify why they should win I
know there's a lot of questions about
alternate realities Avengers time travel
it just like basic plot of the movie
post all your theories in the comments
below we're supposed to get that Spider
Man far from home trailer next week so
I'll definitely be doing videos for that
while you wait for everything click here
to rewatch the trailer a billion more
times and click here for my breakdown of
that spider-man far from home Comic Con
trailer that they dropped a little while
ago thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]